Catherine did she do enough to get
business back on slide I think her
rhetoric was very good the tone was very
good but know that there are elements
there to be concerned about and I think
when we look at the energy camp we need
to look very carefully to make sure that
it is actually carried through to the
ultimate customer yeah very hope that
we've had a lot of rhetoric from the
Conservatives this week in praise of
free markets after the dire trabb's who
heard at labour last week and then she
goes and does this interventions do need
to be looked at extremely carefully and
I have to say I'm also very concerned
that we didn't hear anything more
positive on the question of brexit we
heard some positive remarks about the
free trade agreements we're going to
strike and welcome for the overseas
workers here that's great but we do
actually need to see more than warm
words these days we do actually need to
see progress particularly on those
questions of people transition and
access to trade we bring you in at this
point I mean a lot of people saying
afterwards this is you know she's
basically stolen Ed Miliband's clothing
with great passages of this Beach would
you give her credit for that well there
certainly is some plagiarism not just
from Ed Miliband from Jeremy Corbyn last
week and look Theresa May made just huge
deal about tackling burning in justices
when she came to power last year and
actually her record has been very poor
it's been the opposite and something
like workers and boards for instance
that she said that she wanted to happen
those those have been watered down those
proposals have been watered down it's
not happening on poverty on food banks
on impacts on what she calls vulnerable
people like communities of color have
been very poor from austerity she's
actually been doing the opposite so it's
interesting say her business is not
happy but those of us fighting for
equality aren't happy either so she's
actually really failed big time but
would you give her any credit for the
fact that she's going to start building
council houses again look I mean it's
it's good and again there are these
weird contradictions about free market
and it's good that she's recognizing
that there needs to be intervention
housing market is certainly somewhere
where actually it's failed to deliver
for people it's become more of a matter
of assets rather than a matter of
shelter so certainly but when you look
at the things that she's saying versus
what labour is saying is either unclear
or it's watered down so she's not going
far enough in some cases
even the energy cap it's not clear
what's gonna happen then we'll see next
week but at least for the Labour Pi it's
very clear what they're saying out there
talking about public ownership they're
talking about price caps well let's see
you next week but honestly I think that
most of what she will say will be
watered down and why would anyone trust
her she's rollback on everything she
said last year Catherine would you like
that well we do need to look at the
detail I would welcome what's been said
on housing again that's something which
is very much needed not just for those
who are having difficulty affording
homes but actually we're finding people
are having trouble in the city the
workers that we need to depend on and so
we welcome the moves on housing but we
need to see spades in the ground
the odd thing here though is that she's
committed 10 billion to help to buy an
extension of George Osborne's thing
basically which just stoked up demands I
mean two billion buyers basically if you
price houses at 200,000 pounds each
that's only another 10,000 homes it's
not is it it's a start and it's a very
big issue which we really need to tackle
and indeed we in the City Corporation
are going to be making our own
contribution to that as as our other
London authorities it is it is one of
the biggest challenges that faces our
working population at the moment the
housing question as I mentioned workers
on boards I imagine there'll be a lot of
people in the city breathing a sigh of
relief that Theresa May hasn't gone
through with that I think people are
very concerned to hear the stakeholder
voice and to look at ways and engaging
stakeholders most businesses that I
talked to would prefer to see something
which encourages listening to the voice
rather than absolutely stipulating
laying things down in in law but I think
we're all very keen to explore the best
method of corporate government this
point of house building I mean what
makes you think that the state will be
any better at building homes in the
private sector well there's been huge
the way in which the system works right
now is this very strong incentives to
have profit so we heard Corbin's speak
about last last week about changing the
incentives of the system how we build
affordable housing and how we use public
money and to make sure that we are not
having a kind of profit only system
which has led us to this point where
housing is incredibly unaffordable for
the majority now so it's not just those
on low incomes but
those working in the city which is hard
to believe so you know there is a place
okay clear case for public intervention
and what's really interesting is how
much I was at the Tory Party conference
this week how much Corbin and Corbin ISM
was setting the agenda there they are
clearly quite spoon they clearly don't
have the answer so they're taking some
of what he's saying and watering it down
but actually just doesn't make sense you
either go with intervention or you make
the case for free markets and they're in
this weird middle ground so everyone's
confused businesses confused I'm
confused
yeah I mean that's a fair point isn't it
Kathryn I mean they really do need to
give a full-throated defense of free
markets and we just didn't get that from
the p.m. today she was very strong in
what she said but as I say again we
really need to see some action for
business and I mean it was pleasing that
she recognized the contribution that
business makes to society in the economy
but we need to see absolute clarity and
particularly at this critical moment we
need to see some real movement for
business for the financial related
professional services on on on brexit
and on transition and people
government's obviously the City of
London Corporation is one of the most
powerful local authorities in the land I
mean do you think central government
could be talking to you more they speak
these days actually since the election
we have a very good conversation but I
do think we need to be exploring more
devolution to local levels so that local
and at the local level you can look at
skills you can look at and the issues
that you have for your particular
community but I have to say we are
finding that there's an open
conversation these days on the big
questions facing the sector particularly
on brexit that we're not seeing the
progress that we need all right I swear
to you Pfizer
I mean Catherine mentioned brexit at the
outset did you hear much there that
excited you today no it was very vague
again I just don't get the sense of a
real vision here and where we're going
in terms of any concrete proposals and
it's really worrying it's such a
critical time for this country when we
should be recalibrating the economy we
should be bringing people inside and we
should be addressing inequality my
father Shaheen Catherine McGinnis thanks
both